bonjour pour commencer je citerai la
comédie musicale roméo et juliette et
mais c'est ce qu'il ya de plus beau
c'est de la merde c'est copié sur notre
dame de paris
110 remplacer quasimodo par roméo super
aujourd'hui je reçois christian
christian est l'homme le plus éditeurs
du monde mais vous essayez de vous en
sortirez pendant tg tiers-etat gueule en
commentaire pardon excusez moi j'essaie
de m'en sortir
alors pour ceux qui ne savent pas un
éditeur c'est quoi c'est quelqu'un qui
derrière son ordinateur confond un peu
cynisme et traits d'esprit et qu'il a
critiqué un peu d'être défait par dont
on critique que dalle on déguste tout
haut ce que tout le monde pense tout bas
espèce de vieille mère de 'gros con'
sommes pas au fait du réflexe c'est pas
très grave
comment on devient éditeur christian une
connerie soirée foot avec les potes on
commande des pizzas le livre arrive à
l'heure les pizzas était délicieuse et
décide de mettre cinq étoiles et là mon
doigt a ripé j'ai mis qu'une seule
étoile
qu'est ce qui se passe là j'ai aimé sa
[ __ ] j'ai adoré là vous dites c'est
l'engrenage c'est à dire juste je vous
coupe
excusez moi mais la chemise et en bon
dégueulasse y a pas idée de mettre des
chemises du match comme ça devant les
deux respecté par prompt désolé mais
avec la même pas terrible
fausse route là vous dites c'est
l'engrenage c'est à dire que vous allez
de plus en plus sur les sites internet
pour les cd mauvais commentaires des
pousses rouge à tout va qu'est ce qui se
passe vous basculez un soir de décembre
ouais c'est ça en fait gelé sur une
vidéo c'est le nouveau clip à la mode
qui sortait et là je vois 750 1484 vue 0
pouces rouille et là c'était plus fort
que moi quoi pour ce cru on vous appelle
de raids finger d'appui et ça mettra
l'état pousse rouge jeu pour mettre un
million par jour
en fait vous êtes jaloux c'est ça parle
en bas je dis vous êtes jaloux asie
répète ce jeudi vous êtes jaloux
vous faites quoi la question le jaloux
tu as laissé une bonne critique demers
sa photo de profil facebook
connard pardon mais c'est ridicule
surface de vous mais non c'est plus
facile derrière un portable en plus
vous utilisez un pseudo semapa votre
vrai nom oui progressent de 86 est
totalement mensonger ah oui moi tu lui
92 mais vous vous disiez vouloir vous en
sortir qu est ce que vous faites pour ça
elle c'est d'aller voir des vidéos et de
mettre des commentaires plutôt positifs
ces genres j'adore beau travail je
respecte et n'ont peut-être pas ça mais
du style away sympa peut mieux faire
j'ai souri mais paris - cl de même
pourquoi vous n'avez pas été capable de
mettre un seul pouce vert barrette et
que les pouces verts connard là c'est
quoi vous et à vous et imposèrent
theekoye est écolo l'espèce de fils de p
ô vous arrêter au monde
pardon bah j'ai une surprise pour vous
voilà vous allez mettre votre premier
pouces verts en direct pour nous sur une
vidéo est vrai qu'en ce moment
ouais bon c'est pas meilleur exemple il
joue mal c'est pas très drôle c'est le
gros qui joue mal et ça j'appelle gros
son et vidéo à la semaine prochaine
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
nous avoir suivis bonsoir firth pardon